[Music]
from
brandy to lily james drew barrymore and
hilary duff
actresses are always honored to wear a
cinderella ball gown
cinderella's story will still be retold
a hundred years from now but the only
thing more legendary than the girl
herself
is her fairy tale dress with so many to
choose from
it can be hard to pick a favorite but
we're going to try we're going to look
at 10 different cinderella gowns based
on historical accuracy
design skill fairy tale quality and how
much they capture the magic of the
original
then we're going to rank them at the end
of this video so let's hurry into our
pumpkin carriage
and get started let's start with
disney's original cinderella and work
our way up to the more modern versions
cinderella's classic ball gown might be
blue in our memories
and every piece of disney marketing but
the animated dress
is actually white and silver the
original cinderella takes place in
mid-19th century
france however cinderella's dress takes
inspiration from different time periods
the silhouette is a mid-18th century
shape usually achieved with hoops that
are flat in the front and back
and extend over the hips cinderella's
gown is given volume with a
petticoat-only skirt which was more
popular during the 1830s to 1850s
and usually created a completely rounded
shape instead of just rounding out the
sides
the puffs at cinderella's hips likely
represent looped up skirts
that were popular in the early 1870s but
those usually also had a bunching at the
center of the back
as for the accessories cinderella's
sleeves resemble the high puffed sleeves
of the 1890s
and her long gloves were popular in the
19th century
cinderella's choker was popular from the
1860s to the 1910s
and you probably even have one at home
right now
did you ever see such a beautiful dress
despite aspects of her dress fitting the
19th century narrative
a lot of cinderella's styling reflects
the time the movie was made
the year 1945 saw dresses getting a lot
bigger and fuller
making way for the classic ball gown
other factors of 1950s style
are silhouettes that create a slim
figure with a small bust
narrow hips and a nipped in waist all of
which are accentuated by the dress
of course we can't forget how magical
the dress is what do you notice first
when looking at it there's that sparkle
the volume
and the romantic way it flows when she
dances these are all important aspects
of the classic cinderella ball gown
it's midnight yes so it is
goodbye rogers and hammerstein's
cinderella starring brandy is definitely
a fan favorite
costume designer ellen miroginik
designed brandy's gown by combining blue
and white details that are clearly based
off of the colors disney marketed
the skirt is made of layers of blue tool
with characteristics of youth and
vibrance
this cinderella also has a mix of time
periods it's set in an
old-timey village during no specific
year so the clothing ranges from 19th
century peasant chic
to gowns you would see in the 40s and
50s what's your very first impression
when you take in this dress
is it that it looks just like the
animated gown turned real
because that's what we're thinking it
trades the bunching at the hips for a
peplum
and the sleeves drop instead of stay on
her shoulders but otherwise
the dress combines almost all of the
elements of the original
to keep things fresh this version of
cinderella aims for vibrance in
all its costumes from whitney houston's
fairy godmother to the wicked
stepsisters
bright colored outfits are covered in
sparkles and interesting prints no
single outfit in this movie is boring
tell me
cinderella what would you say
to capture the prince ever after a
cinderella story
is unique because it's historical but
not magical
it takes place in france during the
1500s though the styling isn't
always classically french costume
designer jenny b
van didn't design a traditional ball
gown for drew barrymore
instead the dress is off the shoulder
romantic and embellished and it's really
not a ball gown at all
instead it's danielle's mother's wedding
dress as well as her mother's shoes
which finally explains why cinderella
would end up losing a shoe at the ball
help me find the owner of this rather
remarkable shoe
the wide shoulders and the wings though
not a part of any other cinderella gown
do give the look a fairy tale quality
despite the story lacking magic
how do you feel about the wings there
are some historical inaccuracies like
her style of shoe not being popular till
the mid 1600s but the gown definitely
looks like something straight out of
history
it also has that classic fairytale
quality even though it has almost
nothing in common with cinderella's gown
a servant henry
is this some kind of joke made in
manhattan is one of the more modern
retellings of cinderella where jlo gets
to look spectacular
even though she always does in a
gorgeous pale pink strapless
chiffon gown designed by albert wolski
the shape
hair and necklace just scream modern day
fairy tale
as well as the soft pink color which
seems to stand out even though it's not
very bright
this dress is probably the easiest to
see yourself in
it's not too heavy and it's incredibly
modern even though it has very little in
common with the classic ball gown
it's sleeveless unlike most adaptations
and it doesn't have a full skirt
look i've made so many mistakes already
i just don't want to make it worse
like ever after hilary duff's dress in a
cinderella story
is really a wedding dress given to her
by rhonda her fairy godmother
the gown is white strapless and much
more modern
this dress has a few things in common
with cinderella's ball gown
like a full tulle skirt and some bling
and lace on the bodice that give it a
romantic sheen
the only true accessory to this look is
the lace masquerade mask
making the dress the true focus on the
entire moment i love her dress
when sam and austin dance we can see how
lovely the dress is in motion
and this entire look makes up the
perfect modern fairy tale
we know you wished you were sam when you
watched her become a princess for the
night
not now what i've gotta go
ella enchanted completely remixes the
fairy tale genre
so it's no wonder that ella's ball gown
is pretty different from the classic
when ella is magic into the dress by
lucinda we can see that it's definitely
not her style
the gown starts out as white sleeveless
and iridescent with an overlay on the
bodice that makes the look seem more
romantic
the tight bodice and layered skirt
definitely have cinderella inspiration
but there's not much else they have in
common is there anything else you notice
that really ties the looks together
the dress later gets messed up and ella
ties the skirt up
creating something easier to fight in
she's obviously much happier with her
destroyed dress
and we can't blame her ball gowns aren't
for everyone and one of the biggest
lessons we learned from cinderella
is that the dress does not make the girl
take them
[Music]
one of the most uncharacteristic
cinderella gowns is the red dress selena
gomez wears in
another cinderella story this modern
dress is
loved by fans but it's not very similar
to the classic ball gown
we've never seen a red cinderella dress
plus the gloves are black and the mask
is gold
the dress has a shorter skirt with
different length layers of fabric
instead of a long full skirt and it's
definitely meant for dancing
especially tatango selena does have long
gloves and the mask takes
inspo straight from hillary duff's a
cinderella story
but it's hard to find any more
similarities though this dress is
simpler than a fairy tale gown
it's also much more attainable and
realistic to the modern story
could you see yourself wearing it tammy
if i don't get home by midnight i am
dead
into the woods mixes different fairy
tales but cinderella is one of the
movie's standout characters
the movie takes place during the middle
ages but costume designer colleen atwood
used this as an opportunity to combine
multiple time periods with modern
touches
cinderella is inspired by the 18th
century fashions
especially how campy and over the top
they were the dress is gold lemay fabric
with green hues
capped sleeves and rich beating it's a
lot less full than most other ball gowns
and tool was added to the bust atwood
actually went back to cinderella's true
origins for this one
in the original grimm fairy tale
cinderella's slippers were gold
since her dress came from her mother the
willow tree she wanted to incorporate
gold and the willow's colors atwood also
wanted cinderella running away from the
ball to look even more magical than her
dancing
describing her as a butterfly wing when
she turns
do you think the gold color works well
here or did you miss the classic
blue i didn't attack you i attacked your
shoe i i need it
after the ball is a unique adaptation
because katie who's trying to get back
into her father's fashion company after
her stepmother and stepsisters frame her
has to attend a fashion ball while
alternating between a gorgeous gown
and being dressed as a man since she's
busy disguising herself to get intel on
what her wicked step family is up to
the dress in this version is strapless
like made in manhattan
and a cinderella story but also even
shorter than another cinderella story
it has a bejeweled bodice and a tulle
skirt but resembles a performance dress
like ballet more than a ball gown but
the color pattern on the bodice and
material
are modern fairy tale princess and her
blonde updo
is classic cinderella took my idea
costume designer sandy powell was hard
at work designing the unique dress
cinderella would wear
in the 2015 live action remake to convey
weightlessness the voluminous skirt was
composed of more than a dozen fine
layers of fabric
in different shades of blue turquoise
and lavender
underneath those layers lily james wore
a corset and petticoat
nine versions of the ball gown were
created each featuring 10
000 swarovski crystals and more than 270
yards of fabric
each dress took 18 tailors and 500 hours
to complete
this look echoes some of that 1950s
inspiration in the first film by having
an extremely nipped waist and slight
figure
as well as a very full skirt since there
was no specific time period or country
there was a lot more freedom with the
dress the dramatic shoulders take
inspiration from many other adaptations
as well as the color which is the most
vibrant blue of
all the ball gowns but the butterflies
help make the dress more youthful
as it's important to remember that
cinderella is still young
it's made of glass and why not
time for the ranking we're going to
start at number 10
and work our way up to the very best
dress selena looks fire in this red
dress but other than the story being
loosely inspired by cinderella there's
not much about it that screams fairy
tale
katie's dress is a little more magical
but it's definitely not heavily inspired
by cinderella's iconic look
jlo's pink dress has very little in
common with cinderella's but it gets
number 8 on this list for how much it
makes her look like a modern day
princess
baby hilary duff stuns in this wedding
dress turned ball gown
it gets points for the full skirt and
romantic bodice but it's no classic
cinderella
ella's dress has enough in common with
cinderellas to look like something she
might actually wear
but it's not quite magical enough to
make it into the top five
this one gets points for being inspired
by the original cinderella fairy tale
it's gorgeous and historically accurate
enough but it doesn't have much in
common with the classic cinderella gown
drew barrymore's iconic dress is a fan
favorite and also one of the most unique
gowns
it's pretty historically accurate and
those wings make it truly magical
and you're not engaged
of course the classic gown that we all
know and love would have to make it
somewhere in the top of the list
the dress blends a few different time
periods but it's one of the most magical
of the bunch
and it's the first one that comes to
mind when you think cinderella
randy stuns in her cinderella gown not
having a specific time period helps give
the dresses design more freedom but it
still seems magical enough to be part of
a fairy tale
finally the top spot goes to disney's
live action remake
a big factor here is how much work went
into its creation
and since it doesn't have to fit into a
specific time period
it's both classic and modern basically
this dress is a dream what's your
favorite cinderella
ball gown are there any other fairy tale
fashions you'd like to see us talk about
next
let us know in the comments don't forget
to hit that like button and subscribe to
the things for more
thanks for watching
you